[Music]
how many of you guys
have tik tok i think i've i only have
one
i have one i have one i don't really
post on it though
i deleted it from my phone you deleted
it yeah
i don't use it though i do i deleted it
when i saw that article about like
maybe it was spying on you or something
or they were keeping your information
from your phone i don't remember what it
was but
but then they got the debunk got
debunked and then i was like i don't
want to follow the story anymore i'm
just deleting it
that's true it's uh messy yeah do you
guys have you guys ever given a view
towards uh to a person named charlie
demaglio
well she's uh she got famous for the
the renegade renegade you know more than
a game i i never downloaded
she didn't invent it when another girl
invented it there's a huge she did give
her
credit though eventually gave credit for
that girl but that's what she how she
got known who's charlie the monomallion
he's the number one person
on tick tock with almost almost
100 million followers how often does
that change does it change pretty
frequently is it like because it's
it's tick tock is still pretty like new
right so i'm sure there's a lot of
people that just kind of
get to the top i don't know who number
two is so for like the past year she's
been like
wow so it's a steady
yeah like a straight line up oh [ __ ]
took talking
yeah she's social media royalty she's
got
kardashians and stuff like that at her
level so like she's pretty up there but
this all happened in the span of a year
basically yeah and her sister was young
too right yeah she's 16 her sister uh
16. yeah so charlie's 16 her sister is
uh
dixie and these names dude i know the
names are
a little they're different you know if
you have like 100 million followers like
your brand deals are probably
like starts at 300 grand for a post i
don't know because tick tock was having
trouble with
that but then i don't know there's a
whole thing about like
people with millions of subscribers on
tick tock not getting
that much money yeah well i have a
friend that works at like one of those
agencies that pulls like influencers and
he was just telling me numbers and i'm
like from tiktok yeah
the platform matters platforms the
platform does matter but generally like
if you have upwards of i would say over
eight figures on instagram and then i
guess close to nine figures on tick tock
it's like 200 grand per post
yeah that would make sense damn 300
grand tick-tock
that's a lot of money it's hard getting
up there i'd be surprised if it wasn't
more but you know what's not a lot of
money is uh our
mini mushroom shiitake kit which is only
thirty four dollars
at mk.farm joe you could get that you
know what isn't a million
uh dollars is this a um here for the
vibe dad
you could get that too yeah i'm here for
the vibe i'm feeling it
okay i'm here for the mushrooms do you
have a brand deal over there for nestle
water
what about your shirt gotcha matcha
right here
all the water remember the nestle guy
was trying to
get all the water from everybody
remember him look i just pulled it out
of the trash june
single serving packets there we go you
can get yourself the trash yep
you get a iphone for a thousand dollars
nice
go away for it
[Laughter]
all right back to charlie dimaggio and
her sister so
um dixie has 43 million followers so
it's a
far stretch between the two sisters
one's 16 and one's 19 years old and they
fight about that all the time
hey there's gotta be a little bit of
sibling rivalry like you only made a
hundred grand on your brand deal haha
stupid [ __ ]
to be specific she has she well she had
99.5 million on wednesday
now she has 98.5 she lost the million
followers she watched
100 followers in like literally a day
wow
why we're talking about charlie dimaggio
is that
she is being cancelled and uh
i kind of want to share this i want to
share this video with you and ask you
what you guys think
is that's her version of getting
cancelled from 99 million to 98 million
i'd be down to get canceled any day if
it's if you got up that high
[ __ ] because if you lost a million it
would cut your subscribers in half i'm
talking about percentage-wise right like
let's say i have a hundred thousand
followers and now i'm 99 000 followers
i don't care the [ __ ] true losing a
million
is a lot of people like a million people
are mad at you yeah
i mean i think if you have 99
yourself at age 16 raging hormones and
it probably crushes you and and you know
re-feeling this sense of like
uh like you're a god basically right
she's probably crying into silk tissues
and [ __ ]
yeah so this is this is the clip but
we'll see if she's only
glasses though you know 20 bills
that's how you'll know if she's really
glass half full because like for us
we're like
oh it's just a million [ __ ] that's
nothing that's like when a billionaire
gets
a a million dollar fine you're like
whatever
i don't care i'll wipe my ass with that
money
all right so this is this clip is what
she's being canceled for like i guess
our whole family's being canceled really
but because she's the biggest name in
the family
she is the one like i guess receiving
most of the
you know the cancel stuff the bigger you
get the more haters
that's great more money more problems
more followers more hate yeah so within
in this video though i don't personally
i don't think she does the craziest
thing
in the video but you guys can be the
judge of that so to paint this
uh video they have a youtube channel the
the mario family have a youtube channel
they're doing this like
oh they're all cashing in on it yes
they're all famous even the dad
the mom they're all in here it is like
keeping up with the credit
yes yeah so they're having a dinner it's
the sixth note they're bringing james
charles as their guest
and this is like the first episode of
many is he not cancelled anymore like i
don't know he's always canceled about
where he's canceled i think he survived
whatever
whatever he's being canceled before he
survived he's you know multiple times
i think they always survive though right
they survive and then they cancel
themselves again and then like i don't
know if it's like
on purpose i don't know anymore it's not
even cancelling it's like
muting it's a yeah it's like for a
second they're being muted
and then they come back it's like all
press is good press
they like sometimes people get a lot of
bad press but it ends up working for
them so is kevin spacey like really long
mute
or whatever yeah i think he's actually
diving he was like yeah
all right kelly all right so some people
restart their computer and some people
shut down yes right right
all right some people got a windows 95
and it just says frozen
is that paella that's pai yes they're
eating
so this video is gonna highlight the
partners
hey come on dude look at this where do
you guys came from
this is the dad this is dixie this is
the sister that has
only 43 million oh and then if i scrub
over uh you'll see that james charles is
in the middle oh cool all right
and then you'll see where's that angle
that that's uh what's her favorite
charlie charlie and that's the mom all
right okay
and let's play the video with gavin
newsom
yeah kevin's on the other side of the
camera dinner party there
like ten more people no matter all right
here we go
and like why why now do you want to get
more involved with the business type
stuff because i remember when i first
met you
i was no no get it together you need to
people
you need to be looking at contracts you
need to be looking at this you need to
be understanding dealt with
your muscles because a lot of people
don't but unfortunately that's how a lot
of it
what is that what is everyone laughing
at what is this
oh my god that's a mushroom no it's not
that's a snail
oh so that person talking off camera is
the
family chef all right so this is like
like they got a family shed
they had a family chef i do not feel bad
yeah oh my goodness
and they got they put snails in their
food yeah
some culture nails snails inside the
pipe yeah i didn't know there's a paella
hats now i didn't know that either i
thought it was
like french i want to try it that's good
bro a snail is just an earthy clam dude
you know what i mean i eat snails
it's delicious i eat snails i just
didn't know paella tell about that
what's your problem with snails dude i
like snails i'm pescatarian otherwise i
would eat a smell okay
they don't go in the scene
so then what about sea snails they're
too cute i don't i all
no i don't know okay fine i don't eat
anything with a shell
no clam oh wait sorry i do eat clam and
oysters
like not lobster crab they're
crustaceans i'll eat mollusks
as long as you know your parameters
that's all that matters all right here
we go here we go that's so cute though
so here we go okay it's
kind of cool it's classic and it's
actually
uh uh omen of good luck and fortune
oh cool
is this on their youtube channel yeah
yes this is on the youtube channel
all right listen listen to what charlie
says here too
[Applause]
do we have any dino do we have any
download like this
all right so why is that funny so i mean
i'm bad
what they felt like was wrong with that
scene right there was the fact that
people people people trying to cancel
them right is that
one disrespectful towards the chef threw
up the food
didn't like the food did you actually
throw up you should respect the food and
maybe just spit it out
appropriately instead of like your
audience 100 asian or something
i know right i don't know i was like and
then the other part
you have no matters another part that
really irked the followers or the people
trying to cancel them is
the fact that she mentioned dino nuggets
out of all things they're [ __ ]
delicious
college age like that's what they kids
you know they're kids she's 16
yeah and also who gives a [ __ ] what
they're eating
true give the [ __ ] what they want to eat
they're [ __ ] you know
they they're like they're so different
from because kids you give them premium
[ __ ] they're like oh i want mcdonald's
yeah like that's all they do i don't
know any [ __ ] kid that goes oh you
got a5 wag you
yeah you got truffles yeah oh hell yeah
look at it
there's a lot of 30 year olds that don't
even like that yeah dude it's a taste
who cares bro you said it as half a joke
too
it sounds sarcastic to me like a jokey
way like do we have dino
maggots she's creating content yeah yeah
but it it does seem
spoiled as [ __ ] for sure ungrateful as
[ __ ] for sure yeah very true 100 this
next part in the video that happens at
the very end of their video
and this is kind of like the cherry on
top that really just made people pissed
off
here we go i wish i wish i had like more
time because imagine if i hit
a hundred mil a year after hitting a
mill
was the 95 not enough for you i was just
like saying like
even numbers well all right guys thank
you so much for watching
but that's just i don't know i feel like
it it sounds like greedy it sounds
entitled it sounds entitled it sounds
greedy
for the numbers not there for the
following [ __ ] up though
is they need to know who's watching
yeah because um so like
entrepreneurs right or like business
owners we
talk about money very differently than
if we were a wage earner and it doesn't
mean that one is better or the other
it's just the world is different so like
we keep track
of process and progress based off of
earnings and revenue and return on
investment right and then
it can be easily mixed with like uh
money hungry sales people who are
constantly comparing
based off of how much is being earned
but then like if you have targets and
all that
it's just different like you don't say
this around people who might
not have money at the moment like it's
just you gotta know who's around
not relatable it's not related i'm
talking about followers we're guilty of
that
followers yes because that to me it's
like saying like if conor mcgregor was
like i'm gonna be the first double champ
that guy's cocky like i just got one i
got one belt i'ma get two bells
i think because she's supposed to be
relatable her brain we do this [ __ ] too
dude like we when we're talking we
forget the camera's on here right and
we we're just we forget that there's
inside conversations
that there has to be so much context
explained
because when we watch this we get it
right but at the same time
i know it it sounds mad [ __ ] entitled
it also depends
i think um because we didn't see the
whole video so i think because i kind of
heard a little bit about this and how
people were just saying like
throughout the entire video it just
showcases
how bratty and entitled they are like oh
entire demeanor the way they were
talking to their parents
and the way the parents just take it and
like
but they grew up watching the
kardashians like that was like the role
model for this generation
so how are they not supposed to feel
that way when like they watch that
every day like that's how people with
money they act like this
and they are just kind of bratty but
they're good people you know like
cameras are on
you turn yourself on a little bit for
the cameras to you know where do you
spice things when you watch their tick
tocks or whatever they're following you
they do dances like what do you expect
yeah you expect from them yeah
do you expect honorable moral like
people that
you know what you're getting like yeah
exactly like like you know what you got
yourself into like if you watch
kardashians like you know what you're
getting
look at the way everything's shot it
looks exactly like the kardashian show
yeah it does look like a tv
they're missing is like the the [ __ ]
sound effects of like the cuts and the
shocked faces when they go oh you know
like
they're [ __ ] classy and like the the
what do you call it when they're just
the confessional
shots like that's all you're missing the
other sister is trying to be the kim
who's like being dramatic and then
charlie's like
the chloe or whatever this girl is she's
the
what's your charlie she's this is dixie
okay so she's not she's the older one
she's 19
yeah and the other one is 16. yes and
the 601 has more followers
she's being canceled for basically
talking about her number the number she
wants to reset uh 100 million and for
mentioning dino nuggets back in the day
when i say that i mean like five years
ago um
i remember sam pepper getting cancelled
he was young but he got cancelled for
sexual assault
like that's this is like yeah i don't
know you're you're
kids and also like the people who are
canceling them
they're also children who see it as like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you you have
all of this and you're not great
sure yeah and i and i think that's true
but it's just also like i don't know
like
um let's hear their apology videos and
and this is a good start to their
apology videos very strange the apology
videos are very different in tone
here we go oh this this is dixie the
older one first
the one that was if you were here to
comment like this
so there's flashes hold on one second
know the full story so my family and
i've been working with chef aaron may
for a couple months now working on
content for our channel and working on
content for his channel and
made an amazing friendship and before i
even get into anything i'm so grateful
for every single person that follows me
every single person i care about every
single person i work with every single
person who works with me because i'm
just so grateful of all the
opportunities i've had
so i would never in any way want to be
taken as disrespectful
especially from an out of context 15
second clip
so basically my team knows i throw up a
lot i could throw up at the smell
the thought or the taste of anything so
when they saw the snails they're like oh
let's get her and
try to see if we can get a reaction out
of her you just completely
so basically that clip that wasn't in
the original video is my team and chef
aaron may trying to convince me to try
snail knowing that i would have a
reaction
i love chef and i would never disrespect
him in any way and maybe don't judge
someone's personality over 15 seconds
okay so that's dixie's response and
apology and a lot of people took it as
sarcastic and ungenuine why and she's
providing
genuine the word is and then this is the
other sister
you cannot like me but not attack the
way i look
or the fact that you don't want me here
like that's where i kind of
draw the line and honestly like seeing
sorry seeing how people reacted to this
like
i don't even know if i want to do this
anymore like this is messed up stuff
that people are saying
like people telling me to hang myself
people just like blatantly disrespecting
the fact that i'm still like you're
getting
yeah it's not okay at all
i like people making fun of the fact
that it's just
like a wagon like that's not okay you
can hate on me for whatever i've done
but the fact that all of this is
happening because i
a misunderstanding like i just feel like
that's not okay
and this is the community that i'm in in
the community that i put myself
in i don't know if i want to do that
anymore so she
put herself in a position where she
might even quit the whole thing now
so i mean this is this is a reality to
how [ __ ] up
humans can be just the audience like
a lot of people don't understand that
yes within there
there's people that are just criticizing
or just speaking right
but within that there are real evil
[ __ ] up people
that can't wait for an opportunity to
say i hope you die yeah
i want to kill you one day i felt that
anyway uh we get that family
yeah they want to kill your family they
say a lot of weird [ __ ]
and there's just a lot of hurt [ __ ] up
seriously [ __ ] up human beings that
can't
it's it's so weird it's like they're
like a fan because they're so obsessed
with our content
but at the same time they can't wait to
hurt you somehow
yeah because they're also hurting in
their own way so misery loves company
and so they have to feel like they have
to tear others
down and an easy target is someone on
the internet because they're not
real they don't ever think we'll respond
or we'll read it
and they probably feel like they're
human they're strangely closer to you if
they can actually hurt you
well i think it's also that they see the
lifestyle that you live like
they see the lifestyle that she lives
and there they see that their lifestyle
is nowhere near that and so they're
throwing rocks at it because like they
want to take you down
yeah take you down a peg yeah where they
don't know that like
it's not but i mean i don't know her
everyone's situation but like
i've been on youtube for like 12 years
and it's not
easy being a youtuber and running a
business and creating content like that
and and having a million people's
opinions on you at all times
and we're much older too so at 16. 16
i i don't know what i would have done
but you know what it's crazy like
compared to like what they did
and what kevin spacey did not that big
of a deal at all
very true kevin spacey did he didn't do
like you know well for sure he deserved
the canceling
cancelling stuff but i mean the pandemic
has made people not be able to place
their anger in their
in the right place yeah but it's who's
canceling who right like i think adults
are canceling kevin spacey
and then i don't think their audience
their kids
yeah yeah i feel like um i mean
hopefully she's getting
help because you definitely need
professional help will help
thousand percent and like hopefully
she's able to understand that all this
stuff that's being spewed
her way it's like it's not even about
her it's about the people like
and they're their own pain that they
have to project onto others
the people who write the most negative
comments are actually the most hurt
people
and they're like in so much pain that
they need to release this somewhere
and they do it on things that don't hit
back or
or whatever and it's really sad a bunch
of dino nuggets then
[Music]
you